ça fait huit mois peut-être neuf je suis
plus exactement que j'ai c'est d'être là
raid commando et je vous en ai déjà
parlé plusieurs fois sur la chaîne mais
je vous ai pas parlé d erreurs que j'ai
faites avec des boulettes des choses qui
m'ont un petit peu saoulé des choses que
j'avais pas comprises et ça on va en
parler mais on va en parler juste après
l'intro
[Musique]
il salue les gens n'aient à l'écran
c'est françois pour la chaîne explique
mme encore je suis ravi de vous
retrouver comme à chaque fois sur cette
chaîne on parle de vidéos de montage de
matos de captation tout ça tout ça
aujourd'hui on va parler un petit peu de
cette bête là on va en parler encore
parce qu'il ya plein de choses à dire
dessus la raid commando c'est vraiment
une caméra très très très surprenante et
pas si évidente que ça à utiliser alors
j'ai déjà fait deux vidéos sur la chaîne
pour en parler mais j'ai encore des
choses à vous dire dessus aujourd'hui je
vais vous parler des boulettes un petit
peu que j'ai fait avec cette caméra des
choses que je n'avais pas anticipé parce
que une raide une caméra de signer ça
s'utilise pas comme un boîtier hybride
ça c'est certain je le savais dès le
départ quand j'ai acheté mais il y avait
des choses que j'avais pas forcément
anticipé et tout ça j'ai voulu raconter
dans cette vidéo parce que au final
cette caméra je trouve quand même
qu'elle a quand même un très bon rapport
qualité prix pour rappel le boîtier nu
coûte 6000 euros donc quand on voit le
prix dr 5d a7s 3d et 9 des r3 on peut
légitimement se poser la question est ce
que ça voudrait pas le coup de partir
directement sur une natte et c'est pas
évident c'est pour ça que je vous
racontais mon parcours pour apprivoiser
un petit peu 7 bet light pour m'en
servir à peu près correctement la
première erreur que j'ai faite avec
cette caméra c'est négliger un petit peu
l'accessoirisation alors est pas
complètement débile quand je vais
acheter je savais que une raide nu on
peut rien faire avec bien évidemment il
fallait l'accessoiriser on a un petit
écran ici mais clairement ça ne suffit
pas pour l'utiliser correctement pour
faire sa mise au point sur tout avec des
optiques manuel par exemple donc la
première chose c'était d'acheter un
moniteur je suis parti sur ce small hd
qui a un port sd eye puisque la sortie
vidéo il n'y a pas de hdmi c'est
uniquement dû s direct qui marche plutôt
bien là dessus pas grand chose à dire la
seule chose c'est que j'avais pris ce
moniteur là parce qu'il a une entrée
supplémentaire pour contrôler la caméra
directement sur l'écran tactile et ça
c'est quelque chose que je n'utilise
jamais les menus sur l'écran tactile de
la caméra directement avec les boutons
marche très bien donc j'aurais très bien
pu investir dans un moniteur un petit
peu moins cher voire même prendre un
adaptateur pour mon atomos pour pouvoir
avoir retour un adaptateur sd eye qui
m'aurait coûté moins cher que ce
moniteur là puisqu'au final je n'utilise
pas la fonctionnalité tactile mais ça
c'est personnel je sais qu'il ya des
gens qui utilisaient qui adorent ça je
vous avoue que j'en sors très bien avec
ce qu'il ya sur la caméra autre chose
que j'avais pas prévu d'acheter c'était
la cage je m'étais dit a pas forcément
besoin je met juste un plateau en
dessous j'ai la poignée g l'écran il n'y
a pas besoin de fixer grand chose dessus
et au final je me suis retrouvé à
acheter la cage forcément parce que ben
pour fixer un micro pour fixer une
lumière pour fixer plein de trucs au
final on peut pas forcément le faire
directement sur la caméra même s'il ya
de la visserie c'est quand même beaucoup
plus simple d'utiliser la cache donc
j'ai fini par acheter la cage tilt à qui
est très bien et surtout cette cage on
va pouvoir la montée sur un autre
accessoire dont je vous parlais un petit
peu plus loin dans la vidéo autre chose
très importante ce sont les batteries
alors je suis parti sur ses batteries
générique l'a tout simplement parce que
une batterie comme ça original une canne
ça coûte 250 euros une batterie vous
dire qu'avec une batterie on est à peu
près une heure d'autonomie là une
batterie générique ça coûte 60 euros
donc la malle sont de moins bonne
qualité c'est certain elle fonctionne
mais la caméra ne les reconnaît pas dans
le sens où elle ne dit pas le temps qui
reste pour filmer donc on sait grosso
modo qui a une heure mais on a pas
d'alerté de témoins même si on a des
petites led ici qui nous indique le
niveau de charge elles sont pas
forcément hyper juste le début mais très
vite la fin reste un peu plus longtemps
c'est pas forcément fou et je m'étais
dit ça suffira elles sont pas très très
cher je peux en acheter beaucoup avec le
fait de pouvoir les interchanger une par
une sans éteindre la caméra je me suis
dit c'est cool je m'étais dit c'est pas
la peine d'acheter un adaptateur v loc
et au final ben j'ai acheté un
adaptateur v loc et une vélo alors c'est
un petit peu moins de pratique que ses
batteries là parce que quand on veut
changer de batterie il faut éteindre la
caméra empêche que cette grosse batterie
là qui équivaut à peu près à trois
batteries comme ça hein j'ai 2h30 3h
d'autonomie avec elle coûte 250 euros
soit le prix d'une batterie comme ça
original cannon l'adaptateur il est
approuvé par est donc j'ai un témoin de
consommation d'énergie au final je
voulais faire des économies sur les
batteries et je me rends compte que
c'était peut-être pas forcément la
meilleure chose à faire dés le départ
j'aurais pu acheter ça ça aurait été
très bien aussi enfin niveau
accessoirisation la dernière chose sur
laquelle il ne faut absolument pas
lésiné c'est le câble ace dia il faut
absolument pas un câble ace 10 au 12 g
blindés parce qu'il ya eu pas mal de
retours faits par des utilisateurs qui
utilisaient des câbles qui n'était pas
blindée qui était pas de bonne qualité
ce qui a fait que ils se sont grillés le
port sd est le seul port qui permet
d'extraire de la vidéo de la caméra y'a
pas d'âge des ennemis il n'y a pas de
double less dia il ya un port sd eye et
avec un mauvais câble branché à un
moniteur ou un autre accessoire on peut
tout simplement faire cramer cette
sortie là en plus de sa red ils sont au
courant et ils ont mis ça hors garantie
parce qu'ils partent du principe qu'ils
vous ont prévenu donc mettre un peu de
sous dans le câble autant vous dire que
c'est quand même plutôt important mais
en passons à la deuxième erreur que j'ai
faite et là ça se passe au niveau du
tournage au niveau des réglages et ça
concerne l'exposition alors exposé sur
une red en raid code c'est totalement
différent de tout ce que j'ai connu
avant tout simplement parce que je me
suis rendu compte qu'on pouvait pas
vraiment se fier au retour image qu'on
avait mais qu'il fallait plutôt à les
regarder au niveau de l'histogramme et
des outils d'exposition vous explique ce
qui m'est arrivé plusieurs fois je les
ai utilisés et je regarde un mot
l'histogramme ainsi que mes jauge j'ai
des jauges rgb rouge bleu et vert tu me
dis si mon image est surexposé on
sous-exposés et j'avais vu pas mal de
tutos qui disait qu'il fallait
absolument respecter ça et utiliser les
outils d'exposition sauf que ça m'est
arrivé plusieurs fois d'exposer
correctement les outils me disais que
c'était ok mais mon image était soit sur
aix complet soit sous texte complet
c'est à force de bidouiller que je me
suis rendu compte que les iso sur sept
caméras sont plus ou moins à titre
indicatif autrement dit si j'expose mon
image et que j'applique une sensibilité
de 400 iso si je change mais il faut que
je les passe à 800 ou à 1200 bien
évidemment mon image va changer elle va
être plus clair mais mon histogramme et
mes outils ne vont pas bouger les outils
d'exposition ils vont juste me dire s'il
ya assez ou pas assez de lumière le
réglage de la sensibilité iso il sert
juste en fait à pouvoir avoir un aperçu
de l'image correctement exposée mais on
peut avoir un aperçu totalement
sous-exposés ou surexposées et pourtant
avant exposé correctement avec les
outils je sais pas si c'est très clair
mais grosso modo vous pouvez bouger
autant que vous voulez les iso ça ne
change rien et puis toute façon on peut
le faire aussi en post prod le plus
important c'est les outils d'exposition
qui vont vous dire si c'est bon ou si
c'est pas bon et ça même si c'est
compliqué à comprendre au départ c'est
un gros plus parce que simplement en
regarde ces outils là on sait si on a
exposé correctement ou pas ouais je sais
c'est un petit peu bizarre mais
franchement au final quand on a compris
le système c'est hyper simple
d'utilisation et c'est hyper pratique le
troisième point sur lequel je pensais
que ça allait le faire que j'allais m'en
sortir ça allait être facile c'est la
stabilisation je vous rappelle que cette
petite bête n'a pas de capteur stabilisé
au mieux on peut avoir des objectifs
qu'ils le sont mais il n'y a pas de
stabilisation sur cette caméra donc
m'étais dit avec la poigne et je cale ça
contre ma poitrine je vise je tiens en
dessous normalement ça devrait pas
beaucoup bouger et ça va le faire demain
comment vous dire ça bouge quand même
pas mal hein ça bouge quand même pas mal
donc j'ai dû trouver des solutions je
les monte sur mon goal un crime trois
aces qui encaissent pas mal de poids
mais pour ça j'ai été obligé d'acheter
des petites optique cannon qui marche
plutôt bien mais clairement c'est pas
une solution qui m'a séduit sur le long
terme vous savez que les guiboles je
suis pas ultra fan autant vous dire
qu'avec un tel poids je suis encore
moins fade mais ça a le mérite d'être
possible par contre l'accessoire que
j'ai surkiffé que j'avais au fond d'un
tiroir que j'utilisais jamais et que je
me suis mis à réutiliser et que je
trouve très cool c'est ceci un rig
épaules avec ma cage tilt à j'ai juste à
venir ips est ici ma caméra et j'ai un
set up qui est quand même très très
stable et que j'aime beaucoup alors
quand j'utilise je déplace mon moniteur
sur le côté avec un bras et vraiment ça
c'est un rig que j'ai beaucoup apprécié
c'est un des plus stables et un des plus
faciles d'utilisation ça pèse un peu
mais bon j'ai mes trois points d'appui
je peux le porter ici sur mon épaule est
beaucoup moins fastidieux et beaucoup
moins fatigant que sur un golf ça c'est
clair et net sinon en dernier recours en
enlever j'essaie surtout de faire des
mouvements beaucoup plus doux est
beaucoup plus lent voire pas de
mouvements du tout laver l'eau qu'elles
aident beaucoup parce qu'on peut
vraiment cela calais ici contre le torse
et c'est plutôt cool donc là dessus il
ya quand même moyen de faire des choses
quand même plutôt sympa enfin la
dernière chose que j'avais pas trop
anticiper c'est le slow mon cette caméra
si on veut éviter d'avoir à krupp et
énormément dans le capteur ça va être du
50 voire du 60 images par seconde
maximum 60 images en 4k 50 images ainsi
qu'à mais au format 2 34 bref c'est pas
du tout une caméra qui est fait pour le
slogan on peut aller jusqu'à 120 images
par seconde mais en deux cas donc je
vous raconte pas
8 mm ça devient téléobjectif quasiment
un truc de malade tellement sa crotte
clairement pour les grosses le mot c'est
pas la caméra qu'il vous faut mais d'un
autre côté je reviens du solomo ça me
permet aussi de penser mes plans
différemment et d'essayer de faire le
plus de choses possibles à vitesse
réelle à 25 ou 24 images par seconde et
je me dis que ça change quand même un
petit peu ça fait pas des tartines de ce
logo est allé et je voudrais conclure
sur ça cette caméra elle est très très
cool je l'aimais énormément j'aime
énormément le rendu est là quelque chose
de vraiment unique par rapport à tout ce
que j'ai pu essayer le grain de l'image
ça n'a rien à voir avec tous les
boîtiers hybride que j'ai pu essayer
j'en suis très très content mais ça
reste une caméra de compromis elle fait
pas tout bien elle sait pas tout faire
mais ce qu'elle sait faire elle le fait
de manière incroyable est vraiment le
fait d'avoir un combo avec de l'hybride
mai et 6 2 pour pouvoir faire du run and
gun rapidement avoir quelque chose
d'hyper souple et d'hyper facile à
utiliser et d'avoir à côté cette caméra
là pour des projets un petit peu plus
conséquent et sur lesquels je veux
m'attarder plus longtemps pour vraiment
pensé les choses et bien le fait d'avoir
ces deux là je suis totalement ravi mais
je voulais quand même vous avertir un
petit peu de toutes ces contraintes et
puis juste avant de mettre le coup de
blaster sur le pouce en l'air si vous
avez aimé cette vidéo je vous encourage
à aller voir les deux autres vidéos que
j'ai fait sur la common law où je vous
raconte plein d'autres trucs donc si
vous êtes curieux de voir un petit peu
comment ça marche allez voir ses vidéos
qui s'affiche ici et moi je vous dis
rester curieux et à très bientôt pour
une prochaine vidéo show